Hello, and welcome to this intelligence squared election special with me, Linda,
you were recording on November the fifth,
just two days after the 2020 U S election.
It looks like there's a record turnout by voters and it unprecedented over a
hundred million people cast their ballots early.
Those are still being counted in key States as we speak and to help us
understand what the last 48 hours mean and what to expect in the
coming days. I'm delighted to introduce our guest today. Danielle [inaudible],
she's a former vice president and current senior fellow informed the fence
policy studies at the American enterprise Institute.
She teaches us middle East policy at Georgetown university and is a regular
contributor to NBC news is meet the press.
We're also joined by Josh Clancy, Washington Bureau, chief of the Sunday times,
and previously the papers, New York correspondent,
where he wrote an entertaining weekly column for the Sunday times
magazine. I think that isn't,
that the sentiment for the entire election
is probably the word of the day. Yeah, yeah. And uncertainty.
So as of today we have news outlets, um, which are putting,
uh,
Joe Biden ahead on around two and 64 electoral college votes and Trump
on around 214, but there are lawsuits and challenges,
including whether it's too early to call some of the swing States.
So here is the big question. Uh,
when do you think we'll know who the next us president will be?
Danielle you first? Oh, geez. Thanks for throwing me under the bus.
Um, look, I don't know. Um, I think there are a couple of,
there are a couple of shoes to drop for, for all of us. Um, uh,
the first is the first is whether, um, the first is whether, uh,
Arizona is going to go the president's way. Um,
I looking obsessively at the numbers and pretending to have any
inside knowledge is probably puts me,
makes me have something in common with, uh, with lots and lots of Americans.
But, uh, it doesn't make me any more knowledgeable.
It looks like it looks like Donald Trump is on track.
I think to,
to get Arizona the real question then for him will end up being
Pennsylvania. Um, and he's ahead.
Um, but you know,
Arizona is not going to make any announcements before Thursday night. Um,
Pennsylvania has been unbelievably slow. I mean, you know,
everybody's sort of focused on the fact that we had all these early votes cast,
but what's staggering is how long it's taken to actually count these
votes. And then of course, as you rightly note, there are these,
these challenges.
Although I suspect the challenges are actually going to be a little bit of a,
of a, of a, you know, a flat, uh,
effort because you need a basis to challenge all of these, uh,
all of these election results. And while in Wisconsin,
the president can ask for a recount in other States,
it's unclear what his basis for challenging is. So,
so short story long.
I don't think we're going to know at least till Friday. Um,
but maybe not even them. Thank you, Josh.
Same question to you.
Uh, yeah, I mean, I broadly agree.
I think it's looking like a real up in Arizona, um,
which does that bring us to Pennsylvania and obviously,
and Georgia is still in play too. And actually the remaining,
whatever is 50,000 votes in Georgia, which are being counted with astonishing,
uh, lack of alacrity, shall we say? Um, I think my,
my friend compared it to an Indian wedding reception in its, uh, in its pacing,
um, the Georgia state and play Pennsylvania Democrats are confident about,
I mean, obviously everyone's trying to project confidence at the moment,
but they do think that those votes that remain are breaking very heavily for
them. It's the mail-in ballots,
which we would expect to vote to break democratic. Um,
and they think Pennsylvania will end up being actually quite comprehensive
victory, um, more so than say Wisconsin. Um,
but it's like pulling teeth at the moment.
We just have to wait for them to count it. And every hour that goes by,
uh, becomes a little bit more fraught. And, you know,
the Trump campaign is obviously launching these lawsuits. And I agree with, um,
Danielle that I think some of them are possibly a little bit frivolous. Um,
but they're also hosting press conferences.
You have Trump on Twitter saying stop the count. Um,
so this is a little bit of a somewhat volatile situation. Um,
fortunately we haven't seen any major unrest of discord at the moment.
Um, but yeah, Democrats do seem confident about,
about Pennsylvania and if they get parents of any, uh,
comfortably that's the ball game. Um,
but unfortunately we have to all sit here in purgatory until, until the,
until the count is done.
All right, what can I hold you to, to this Friday? Um,
announcement typically
we don't find out until the weekend, we're going to come back to you.
And for me is that I need to know by the time I write my copy for Sunday's
newspaper. So it has to be decided by Saturday afternoon. Yeah.
I think that has to be determined
pretty much every American election so far. Yeah, absolutely.
Um, I guess next question I'd like to get your take on is how has the election
played out like you thought or have the results and surprised you,
including the congressional races obviously. And the Senate was at one point,
I think very much being watched as well. So at Danielle,
you face your own, um, how's the election and surprise me. Um,
it doesn't surprise me that Donald Trump did much better than people expected.
Um, I mean, you know, again, the problem for anybody, uh,
is that, is that you want to,
you want to believe the data that you see the problem is that polling isn't
really data, right?
It's it's because you don't actually know what the inputs are
and that's, that's the problem. And so, you know,
one thing I think we can be absolutely certain walking out of this election with
is that the biggest losers in America are pollsters other,
the Republicans, all the Democrats, but these pollsters who, who, you know,
imbued the public with this sort of superior sense,
that things are going to happen a particular way and they're just wrong.
They're wrong. And it's, and it's actually a little bit in my line. Um,
so am I surprised, um, I'm surprised that Susan Collins in Maine pulled it out.
Um, but you know, that's terrific. Um, because she's, uh,
she's a good Senator and she's a moderate and she deserves to be reelected. So,
um,
am I surprised that that the Republicans are going to keep the majority in the
Senate, which I think is likely to be the case? Um, a little, yeah, actually,
because, um, because that was great. Um,
but it was a really rough election for Republicans. So it's a big achievement.
My surprised about the results for Donald Trump. Again, same thing, you know,
um, a little bit,
but the problem for us in America now is that we can't be honest about what we
think if you're a conservative, you're not allowed to say,
so what you have is a lot of people who are very vocally anti Republican,
and there's this whole sort of shadow group of people who are either Republicans
or conservatives, or just Trump voters, who you don't hear from. Uh,
I think everybody's, I think everybody's a little bit surprised,
but what's the most surprising thing, not the Senate,
not how it went in any of these States.
What the most surprising thing is that for four years, um,
Republicans have been labeled racist. Donald Trump has been labeled a hater and,
and he's contributed a great deal to those labels.
This isn't something that came out of the blue to, to, to smear him.
He has helped in that regard.
And yet his performance with minorities is nothing short
for a Republican. And particularly for a man of Donald Trump's Delt,
this performance is nothing short of spectacular and a great,
great opportunity for the right to actually understand that its coalition
isn't based on color. It is, it is based much more on ideas,
rather a longer answer than you wanted. Sorry, I apologize.
No interesting stuff. I think once we see how the various, um,
votes in terms of demographics, um, play out,
I think there's quite a few trends there that we'll need to, to keep an eye on.
Um, but Josh, same question to you, you know, um,
have the results surprised you has it out, like you thought. Um,
and of course, you know, beyond the presidency,
anything around the Congress and Senate, Hmm.
This is the first American lecture I've properly covered.
And so it was interesting experience in that I did a lot of reporting on the
ground, um, which was somewhat, uh, hazardous in COVID terms,
but I sort of went through it anyway.
And a lot of American reporters didn't a lot of the American news organizations
actually were pretty cautious around that. And there was the kind of some,
something of a politicization around it too.
And the things I kept seeing on the ground were really significant enthusiasm
for Trump. I was out with boaters for Trump and was constant.
I was at car rallies for Trump, with the Cubans in Miami.
And I kept seeing like big, big numbers and big passion for Trump.
And then I would come back to the state and I'd look at the polls and I would
talk to the posters and they would tell me, that's lovely,
ain't going to matter. And it may not, but it was that,
and it was underreported. Um,
and it seems like the media and the post has made a lot of the same mistakes
that they made in 2016,
despite the fact that there were supposed to be a great place more of most of
2016 and everyone sort of walked around with kind of hair shuts for six months.
Um, so to my mind,
I wasn't that surprised I noticed is it's to say that in hindsight,
but I did think Trump would out before his polls,
I did think I was going to Israelis in the last couple of weeks.
They were impressive. I mean, they were energetic. He was on,
he was on comic form. He had great, um, charisma.
They were decent numbers that and Biden was doing nothing. I mean,
he was doing these kind of staged speeches and I understand that he wanted to
message about the gravity of the pandemic and he's right to do so,
but just in terms of the, the, the, the power of the campaign, uh,
I think it did make a difference with Trump.
And I do think the posters are just bad at reaching media skeptic,
rural white conservative voters. I just don't think they're waiting.
It's not just their education. They're just not reaching them.
I don't think these people want to speak to pollsters from Sienna college or
Monmouth college or wherever it is. Um, so I wasn't shocked,
um, gun to my head before the election, and I said, Biden close.
And that is probably where we're going to end up. Um, and you know,
I definitely wasn't surprised by Florida.
I really always thought Trump would win forward it just from when I went down
there and saw the way, uh,
the Latinos in Miami were feeling about socialism.
And I don't think the Democrats realized how damage it and the kind of Bernie
AOC self-proclaimed socialist movement had been
in certain courses. It actually did well for them in other courses.
And actually we shouldn't forget that they did very well with their teenagers in
Arizona, for example, at 10 good numbers out there. Um,
so yeah, not surprising. Um, the Senate seems really kind of, uh, you know,
I think it's important to realize that Joe Biden didn't have coattails.
He was not a, someone who built a real movement.
People voted for him primarily because they to get rid of Trump.
And so he didn't create this kind of mass momentum behind the party and bring
other candidates along with him. So it's a pretty, uh, if he does win,
you know, he doesn't have a great mandate. He doesn't have the Senate, uh,
is going to be pretty, pretty tough, four years full. It might say.
And Danielle could president Trump still win the election and given where
we stand now. And if so, what is his path to victory?
So, um, could he still win the election? Uh, yes.
Arizona has to turn around, uh, for him. Uh,
I do think that's going to happen. Um, I agree that, um, I sort of,
I agree with, with, uh, with Josh that, um,
that the Democrats are confident about Pennsylvania. Um, dunno.
Honestly, I just, I just don't know. Um, and you know,
my pre election skepticism has only been enhanced, um,
because, uh, because you know, it's hard to believe.
It's hard to believe the press.
It's hard to believe the reporting and it's hard to know. And, uh, and you know,
everybody keeps saying, well, let every vote count. And the answer is, yes,
every vote has to count if he wins Arizona and Pennsylvania,
then he's got a path. Um, if he doesn't, then he doesn't because,
uh, Scott Walker,
former governor of Wisconsin has warmed that he's not going to get the votes.
It's only 20,000 in Wisconsin,
but that he's not going to get the votes he needs from a recount. I mean,
you know, anything can happen. And w what is,
what is frankly weirder to me is this
trend of the last 20 years for these split decision or elections
that are, you know, 5,000 votes, a thousand votes,
10,000 votes apart in a country, the size of America. And yes,
of course we're only going on a state by state basis,
but even then we're a bloody big country, you know, it is, it is,
is quite remarkable. Um, so, you know,
that's his path forward. It, I think it's, I think it's doubtful.
Um, but, but, uh,
you know, it's 2020, you know, I mean, immediate right to hit all of us.
And frankly, it wouldn't be that surprising
2020 has been sent here just very quickly. Josh,
do you think Trump could still win the election?
Yeah. I mean, if you look at the betting markets now, and there's a lot of data,
they have to make their heads, not just polling they're looking at anymore.
Uh he's I think he's about 85% Biden,
and I put myself around there as well. Um,
there is a very narrow path for Trump here.
I don't quite see all the votes that come in in Pennsylvania.
He would have to utterly defy expectations, um,
in terms of that partisan leanings, uh, think, yeah,
Arizona's hopeful for him,
but I don't think Pennsylvania is that hopeful for him.
And therefore neither is the whole ball game. So, uh,
we have seen miracles and Trump and, you know, they it's possible Pennsylvania.
So close. There is a lawsuit in Pennsylvania about, um,
votes that come in postmark after election day itself that went to the Supreme
court and got stayed and could go back to the Supreme court if it's
really, really, really, really close. And those votes matter, the newly, uh,
enhanced conservative majority on the Supreme court could theoretically rule
against those ballots. Now, uh, it was full four previously.
So like there are dilemmas of light if you're Trump and the Trump campaign,
but it's glimmers, I would say it's a long shot.
Danielle.
And I think you mentioned before that the legal challenges may not and selves
amount to a significant, uh, um, and a, uh,
an impact. Um, but you know,
Josh has mentioned this could go to the Supreme court. Um, do you think,
uh, you know, what would your take on an equal challenge in the Supreme court?
Which of course we saw, um, in a Bush versus Gore, right? So the, the,
the Pennsylvania situation is different and here I'm not a lawyer,
I'm parroting a very good piece by Andy McCarthy, who is a lawyer, um,
over at national review who just really laid out, um,
exactly what the Supreme court situation is.
So it's important for people to understand there's one question about a legal
challenge to the vote that's, um, you know, that's,
that's, uh,
something that is a post election filing about the
propriety of the electoral process of, uh,
of the count of the legitimacy of the count or in the case of a very close race
or recount that's one thing. Okay. And that's actually,
you know, that's not based on what we all think on Twitter, or, you know,
what you heard from your neighbor who read it down the street. You know,
it's not that I, and so much of our politics is that,
but this is,
this requires actual legal grounds in order to challenge
and lawyers and judges are actually serious people.
So that's one question on the Supreme court question, which Josh mentioned,
which is, is rather complex. Um, there,
you have a situation where actually Trump does correctly have a glimmer of hope
because the court, um,
the court addressed a challenge to the extension
of, um,
the extension of voting in Pennsylvania prior to
the vote and the court didn't decide the court basically sent it back
to Pennsylvania,
but that challenge still stands and what the court did. And again,
you know, more detail than most people want, but what the court did,
which Josh alluded to is that they separated out the ballots that were
received according to previous system and the ones according to
the new system. And, and again, he's completely right.
If it is a slim lead,
then that may actually make a difference. Uh, if people voted very late,
if, um, if, if people voted, um, if people voted late,
if their votes came in late, and it's not a, um,
it's not a partisan issue,
it's a question of who has the right to change the rules. And when,
and so the Supreme court could actually come back and John Roberts,
doesn't like these sorts of votes, as we've seen repeatedly,
he will actually vote with, with, with the liberal side of the court,
in order to ensure that the court doesn't get stuck in the middle of
politicking, but in some ways, those days are done, right,
because he's no longer the deciding vote. Now,
the court has a majority with Amy Coney Barrett there,
the conservatives have a majority with any Coney Barrett, but, you know, unlike,
I would say that the liberals on the court,
the conservatives on the court are actually conservative. In other words,
they're not going to want to interfere here either. So again,
a pathway, a glimmer, perhaps a little more than a glimmer, but yeah.
Thank you. Um, Josh, the, you know, you mentioned, um,
president Trump is challenging the process, um, as unfair, um, and, you know,
think we have seen, um, protests outside of polling booths, you know,
just say a bit more about what you, your take on his comments.
And also, do you think that these protests could escalate?
Why is coming ridiculous? I mean, he's, he's tweeting to stop the count, uh,
which isn't even what he's advocating. I mean,
they want to stop the count in Pennsylvania, but finished the count in Arizona,
uh, which is farcical. So, you know, while the, the,
some of the actually going to have, it just may have some, uh, legal merit,
his tweeting it's ridiculous, and it's dangerous. It is dangerous. I mean,
so far the system has, has creaked, but not cracked.
And in some ways we were helped by how much Trump and the Democrats
Telegraph, this, we were prepared in advance.
We knew Trump was going to do this.
And we knew that there might be this blue shift we'd been talked about in a
thousand articles that actually,
it might look like Trump who had won on the night,
but actually if you count all the and votes, it could shift.
And so we were quite well prepared for this Democrats message very hard on this.
And what's been interesting is that key Republican and conservative
institutions,
whether it be at Mitch McConnell leader of the Senate or Fox news have not
gone along with Trump in his more absurd pronouncements,
they obviously are giving the challenge of time of day,
but they haven't got on board with Trump and Rudy Giuliani and Eric Trump
saying, well,
this is all kind of Chicago politics and people sort of stealing ballot boxes in
the night and whatever. There's no real evidence of that. Uh,
and until find some, they should stop alleging it, frankly. And it is dangerous.
We haven't seen you. You're right. There has been,
there was a incident at a Detroit polling station. There's been some,
some unrest in Arizona it's really worrying, right. I mean,
we may never want to see that. Um,
but I think the fact that we've prepared for it by the media,
by the Democrats, w we've been expecting this weeks, we've been expecting.
I mean,
I could've told you six months ago that Trump would tweet something about fraud
on hourly while we were waiting for the result. And you just know he's going to,
and it almost feels sort of strangely performative on one level,
but it is dangerous. And the longer this goes on,
I guess the more potential for from rests, um,
emerges. So, yeah, we definitely want a result by, uh, Danielle said Friday,
um, in time for my paper and the rest of the savior of American democracy.
So fingers crossed for that.
And Danielle,
is there a real threat that we won't see a peaceful transfer of power if Joe
Biden wins? You know, um,
I, first of all, I don't think that we should put all of the blame, uh, on, on,
on, uh, on Trump, uh, disgruntled Trump voters here, uh, you know,
there are riots going on in Portland right now.
I can't quite figure out why or what about since it's Oregon,
but perhaps it's the fact that it didn't,
they legalize all drugs drug use.
Maybe it's just, uh, maybe it's just drugs. Um, but
I don't think, I don't think that's very realistic.
The problem is while I think Donald Trump could be enthusiastic
about, uh, about resisting. Um, if,
if there's some question of, uh, of the legitimacy of the victory,
um, uh, of a Biden victory,
I don't think there's anyone around him who will enable that.
And that includes vice president pants. That includes, um,
the Senate majority leader, Mitch McConnell.
It includes really most of the president's cabinet. Um, and so,
you know, that's number one, number two, if Biden wins, I think Donald Trump,
the first thing he's going to do is start thinking about 20 to 24.
And he doesn't want to put himself in super curious,
a position that he's simply not credible.
So I guess I'm a little bit less worried about that. Then,
then people say also, you know, Trump has a lot of stories, a lot of Twitter,
but when it comes down to what he does, this is a lot less risk.
He's really a lot of buck and not as much bite in terms of,
in terms of the threats he makes and the, and the emotions he says up.
And Josh, you talked earlier about how the polls, um,
at this point, um, it's a closer race than, um,
some of the polls had suggested many of the polls suggested. Um,
do you give us your take on whether Trump is, is the, of the Republican party,
regardless of whether he wins or loses?
Yeah, I, I think it is. Um,
I think he's turned out the highest, uh,
the highest election propo, uh, population, uh, you know,
it was at 68 million people that voted for him.
That's more than voted for Obama in Oh eight. That's a lot of Americans. Um,
so yes, I think Trumpism is here to stay. What that means,
uh, is quite contingent. It's contingent on. Obviously if he, if he, if he wins,
then you know, Trump's Trumpism and said to stay. If he loses,
then the process of, of reinterpreting Trump after Trump,
um, begins.
And there is an interesting cohort of people in position to do that.
People like Mark, a Rubio who has pivoted somewhat politically in the Trump era,
people like Josh Hawley from Missouri, a young Senator,
people like Tucker Carlson, the Fox news presenter who's enormously influential.
Um, and then there are other sort of more traditional Republicans.
Mitch McConnell loves still be enormously powerful.
You have Nikki Haley down in South Carolina,
who's probably more corporate friendly Republican. So there,
there will be a process of working out what is Trumpism without Trump.
What happens when you take away the Twitter feed and you take away this
enormously charismatic figure at the center, though,
he will still be on the sidelines.
Will there have power wielding his Twitter feed, uh,
possibly starting a TV network, possibly planning to run again? I mean,
I don't truly think he would have become president again,
but I certainly could see him floating it for some period of time.
So it's a kind of messy rebuilding process. What they have going for them.
The Republican party is they will have control of the Senate.
They have remade the judiciary. So they still have a lot of power,
even if Trump loses. And they're in a position, I guess,
to try and triangulate between what Trump has been and what their
future will be. And Danielle points out, you know,
that they did better than expected among ethnic
minorities.
There is the sort of seedlings of a multi-racial more working class coalition
there, but it is still a party of plutocrats, of magnates,
of people who, um, you know,
like very low taxes and free business enterprise. So there are,
you know, co CA there are different influences in the party and they will,
they will have to sort of work out who they are. post-Trump.
Yeah. You want it to come in plutocrats? I'm sorry. Jeff Bezos,
Mark Zuckerberg. Oh,
I'm sorry. Democrats.
All of them beyond say Democrats,
not just, not just,
not just plutocrats,
but the potty of the filthy rich and Hollywood,
you know? No, your, your assertion is not, uh,
is not backed up by the facts.
I didn't say that Democrats weren't run by Patriots.
I'm just saying that there is still a huge talk about like the mining industry,
the oil industry, the sort of captains of,
of middle American industry in the Heartland are still firmly Republican and
still tie a lot of the bills. So it's not like.
But what about wall street? What about those,
those labels? Get you in trouble though. You know that that's,
that's why people don't,
this is why people don't trust the press is because when you call.
What would you say, Sheldon Adelson? Isn't a polluted Pratt.
I would say, I would say Sheldon Adelson would love to be called a plutocrat.
The point here is that you didn't mention the plutocrats of the left.
And I would say then probably you have numerous on the left.
Yeah. And that's why they raised one reason. They raised so much more money,
but we were talking about this.
It all and wasted it all.
I could let this go.
[inaudible] okay. Let's talk about the Democrats some more,
which is I'm Danielle, how significant is a Joe Biden win for the Democrats.
Um, and, um, some have described Biden as a return,
as a vote day, the return at,
for the return to normalcy in America. Um, do you think that's the case?
Um, I think we're really going to have to see, you know,
what a lot of people fear is the Joe Biden is just the friendly face
of the new democratic party.
And I think it's going to be up to if he,
if he is ultimately crowned the winner,
it is going to be up to him if he's up to
it, uh,
to actually prove that because all things being equal,
the democratic party is not Joe Biden's democratic party.
The democratic party is much more the party of Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders. It's much more the party of the elites than it is the party of,
you know, the, the grassroots, at least in my perception. Um,
and so it's going to be an uphill and uphill battle. I think, you know, again,
a lot of his, if,
if Biden is ultimately the Victor who he chooses
for his cabinet, who he, um, how he chooses to govern,
um, what he embraces as, as appropriate policies, you know,
that his, his plans were very far left,
but he kind of execute them with a Republican Senate. Will that help him?
Will that further isolate him? You know, I don't know. I really don't. Um,
the only thing I can say is that, uh,
is that it will be in for many, many people,
a welcome return to just a little bit less drama in
American politics. And that I do feel sure of.
Thank you, Dan. Now, final question to you, Josh. Um,
what does this election mean for the rest of the world?
Could we see a shift away from America first, um,
and return to the United States playing a more active role in the international
system? What does it mean for democracy?
So just a really small question to finish out.
What obviously yeah, it depends who wins. If we, if we see if Trump wins,
then we will have more of the same on foreign policy. Um,
and we know what that is tough on Iran, uh,
adversarial towards China. Um,
if Biden wins that then, you know,
w they've laid out a lot of what they want to do. They want to,
or at least conceptually, they want to rebuild alliances.
They say they possibly want to end the Iran deal.
Although they might have a tricky job doing that.
They want to focus on climate change. And once we enter the Paris climate cords,
they will do that. Um,
and they want to refocus on Europe.
They want to rebuild relations with Germany and the EU. Um,
and they will probably remain quite adversarial to pause, trying to,
because that has been a really a big shift across Washington, you know,
across American foreign policy and which 10 years somewhat precipitated by
Trump. Um,
but I don't think they will be as adversarial or they will look for different
ways to manage China. Um,
and there are still some sort of Obama era restorationists, uh,
in the Biden camp that maybe don't maybe want to work with turn a little bit
more. They see China as someone they need to work with on climate change,
for example. Um, so, and foreign policy, you know, if he doesn't,
if he's president Biden and he doesn't have their product and he doesn't have
the Senate and foreign policy is pretty one of the only areas you can do
anything. Um, it would be interesting to see what they do with the middle East,
the peace deals that have been signed between Israel and some of its neighbors,
um, which are Trump Herrera, achievement.
I don't know that they will necessarily support more of that.
Um, so that's sort of interesting, um,
foreign policy is gonna be an interesting area.
I think a lot of people will initially breathe a sigh of relief because Trump's
just so stressful. Um, but then perhaps realize that truly
the welds will remain Nazi and complex and Biden may not have that many
solutions for it.
All right. Danielle, same final question to you. Um,
what this election mean for America's role in the world and democracy and et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Well, I think it just means that our democracy works and, uh, and, and, uh,
what does it mean for foreign policy? A lot will remain the same. Um,
I think, uh, as Josh said correctly, um, on Iran, you know, I think again,
that depends the running stuff to play ball. Um,
they've got their own election next year, uh, and, uh,
that I think is going to make it difficult for them to play ball right now.
So we'll have to see, uh, as much as, uh,
some of the figures,
the sort of Obama era retreads lurking in Biden's circle are desperate
to rekindle their friendship with their Iranian buddies. Um,
it might be a little tough on China, Russia, you know,
all I think we really can expect. So, you know, I, one I,
a good thing and a bad thing, a good thing is we can expect a change in style,
you know, less rudeness, uh, what my,
my former boss used to call making the world safe for cocktail parties.
There's going to be a lot more comfortable cocktail parties and abide in the
Euro and the Biden foreign policy.
The things that I worry about are that contrary to what many people think the
Trump administration has actually been really,
really solid on a lot of human rights, human freedom issues. Okay.
Gone after the Chinese, on the wiggles gone after them on Hong Kong,
gone after the Russians on their, uh, on their activities,
particularly in Europe, but also in their near abroad.
Something that the Obama administration was terrible about. Um, frankly,
and, uh,
so I worry that we're not going to be as forthright in defense of,
in defense of those values, which I know sounds funny. Um,
but that actually is the reality. And so, you know,
when Josh says something like, yeah, you know, it's been a really,
or a peace in the middle East under Trump,
but I'm not sure that's going to continue on there,
but that's actually bad news. Um, but on the whole,
I think we shouldn't expect any real seismic changes in foreign policy
and, uh, and, uh, uh, that's not,
not to the bad, thank you both very much. We're out of time. Um,
it's been a fantastic discussion and I think I'm going to take away, um,
one phrase in particular making the world safer for cocktail parties. I mean,
that's, that's going to be a priority along with Josh, his column for this week,
Sunday times. I mean, clearly these are, yeah, absolutely. Exactly.
No you to have an absolutely brilliant Danielle Pletka and Josh Glancy,
what a wonderful discussion.
And thank you all very much for tuning in to this intelligence squared video
podcast. I'm Linda you,
and we wish you a very good day as we now await the outcome
of the us election. And of course,
I'd be remiss if I just didn't point you to the intelligence squared.com
website for more podcasts and terrific events. Thank you all.
Thanks. Thanks, Linda. Cheers. Thank you.